Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. During the 1950s and 60s, Australian reporter and journalist Rupert Murdoch became the senior executive of his own private news proprietor company. After acquiring a number of newspapers in Australia and New Zealand, Rupert's enterprise expanded into the United Kingdom and in 1969, he attended an auction for the largest circulating national gazette, The News of the World.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用上或我们网站上的本期节目简介。在 20 世纪 50 和 60 年代，澳大利亚记者兼报人鲁珀特·默多克成为其私人新闻出版公司的资深高管。在收购了澳大利亚和新西兰的多家报纸后，鲁珀特的商业版图扩展到了英国。1969 年，他参加了一场拍卖会，竞购发行量最大的全国性报纸——《世界新闻报》。
A spirited bidding contest ensued, wherein Rupert defeated the £34 million offer from business rival Robert Maxwell, securing ownership of the newspaper and its sister publication, The Sun. Having secured his position as chairman of The News of the World Group, Rupert entrusted the role of the company's deputy chairman to 60-year-old Alec Mackay, an Australian newspaper executive with over a decade of industry experience. Alec had spent the previous 12 years in England working for Mirror Group newspapers, proprietors of The Daily Mirror and The People, amongst others. It was whilst working for Mirror Group newspapers that Alec was poached by Rupert Murdoch to spearhead his recently acquired publications. Alec lived with his wife Muriel in South West London's
随后展开了一场激烈的竞标战，鲁珀特击败了商业竞争对手罗伯特·马克思韦尔 3400 万英镑的出价，成功获得了该报及其姊妹刊物《太阳报》的所有权。在巩固了自己作为《世界新闻报》集团主席的地位后，鲁珀特将公司副主席的职位交给了 60 岁的亚历克·麦凯，他是一位拥有十多年行业经验的澳大利亚报业高管。亚历克在过去的 12 年里一直效力于英国的镜报集团（Mirror Group newspapers），该集团拥有《每日镜报》和《人物报》等知名报刊。正是在镜报集团工作期间，亚历克被鲁珀特·默多克高薪挖走，负责领导他最近收购的出版物。亚历克与妻子穆丽尔住在伦敦西南部
upscale district of Wimbledon, near the world-famous tennis club. The couple's Georgian-style manor, titled St Mary's House, was situated on Arthur Road, a quiet, leafy street framed by spacious villas, home to London's professional elite, stockbrokers, bankers, and business executives. In December 1969, Rupert Murdoch and his wife Anna made plans to holiday in Australia over Christmas. During their absence, Alec Mackay was assigned to the role of acting chairman of the News of the World Group and tasked with overseeing Rupert's business duties. As acting chairman, Alec was provided with the Murdoch's deep blue Rolls-Royce and its accompanying chauffeur. On December 19, 1969, Rupert and Anna Murdoch departed for their Australian getaway.
的高档住宅区温布尔登，毗邻世界著名的网球俱乐部。这对夫妇的乔治亚风格庄园名为圣玛丽宅邸，坐落在亚瑟路上。这是一条宁静、绿树成荫的街道，周围环绕着宽敞的别墅，居住着伦敦的专业精英、股票经纪人、银行家和商业高管。1969 年 12 月，鲁珀特·默多克和他的妻子安娜计划前往澳大利亚度过圣诞节。在他俩不在期间，亚历克·麦凯被指派担任《世界新闻报》集团的代理主席，负责监督鲁珀特的业务职责。作为代理主席，亚历克获得了默多克深蓝色劳斯莱斯汽车及专属司机的配备。1969 年 12 月 19 日，鲁珀特和安娜·默多克启程前往澳大利亚度假。
Ten days later, on the morning of Monday, December 29, Alec Mackay was picked up from his home in the company's Rolls-Royce and driven to the News of the World Group office in central London, where he remained for the rest of the day. 55-year-old Muriel Mackay dressed in a green woollen jersey suit, a black and white check-top coat, and cream-coloured leather shoes, and headed out in her Ford Capri to run some errands. She went shopping and visited the dentist, returning home to Wimbledon at 5pm. After finishing work for the day, Alec Mackay was chauffured home, arriving to St Mary's House at 7.45pm. When he reached the front door, Alec noticed some sheets of yesterday's newspaper on the ground from the People publication,
十天后，即 12 月 29 日星期一早晨，亚历克·麦凯坐着公司的劳斯莱斯从家中出发，被送到位于伦敦市中心的《世界新闻报》集团办公室，他在那里呆了一整天。55 岁的穆丽尔·麦凯身穿一件绿色羊毛针织套装、一件黑白格子外套和一双乳白色皮鞋，开着她的福特卡普里车出门去办点事。她去购物并看了牙医，于下午 5 点回到温布尔登的家中。亚历克·麦凯结束一天的工作后，乘车回家，于晚上 7 点 45 分抵达圣玛丽宅邸。当走到前门时，亚历克注意到地上有几张昨天的《人物报》，
dated December 28. He pressed the doorbell with three short rings and one long, a special code designed by Muriel to signal when her husband was at the door. The precaution was established after a burglary at the Mackay's home months earlier in September, which had claimed most of Muriel's jury as well as her sense of safety. Since then, she had also installed a chain lock on the front door, keeping it secured in its latch at all times. Even with these safeguards, Muriel refused to open the door until she confirmed it was indeed Alec standing on the other side. When Muriel failed to come to the door, Alec rang the doorbell three more times, assuming his wife was upstairs and out of earshot. When his rings went unanswered, Alec twisted the handle and was surprised to
日期是 12 月 28 日。他按了三短一长的门铃，这是穆丽尔设计的一个特殊暗号，用来暗示她的丈夫已经到门口了。这一防范措施是在几个月前的 9 月份麦凯家中发生了一起入室盗窃案之后设立的，那次盗窃案不仅偷走了穆丽尔的大部分珠宝，还夺走了她的安全感。从那以后，她还在前门安装了一条防盗链，使其随时挂在插销上。即便有了这些安全防范措施，在没有确认门外确实是亚历克之前，穆丽尔依然拒绝开门。当穆丽尔没有来开门时，亚历克又按了三次门铃，以为妻子在楼上没有听到。当他的按铃没有得到回应时，亚历克转动门把手，惊讶地
discover the door was unlocked, the chain unlatched and dangling by the door frame. He entered the house, noticing the lights were on inside, but his calls for Muriel were met with silence. Further within the entrance hallway, a large chair had been pulled away from a wall and now stood in the center of the corridor. Muriel's handbag lay open on the floor, its contents scattered about, along with more sheets of the People newspaper dated December 28. A two-and-a-half inch strip of a lustoplast tape was twisted over on itself on a table, while a large quantity of bailing twine was tangled in a messy bundle on a chair. The hallway telephone had been ripped away from the wall and was overturned on the floor.
发现门没有锁，防盗链也没有插上，正挂在门框旁。他走进屋里，发现里面的灯亮着，但他对穆丽尔的呼唤却只得到了沉默的回应。再往里走，在门厅里，一大把椅子被从墙边拉开，现在正立在走廊中央。穆丽尔的手提包敞开着扔在地板上，里面的东西散落一地，旁边还有几张日期为 12 月 28 日的《人物报》。桌上放着一截两英寸半的强力胶带，卷成一团，一大捆捆扎绳凌乱地缠绕在椅子上。门厅里的电话被从墙上扯了下来，倒扣在地板上。
Alec's eyes were then drawn to a foreign object resting on the nearby writing desk. The machete-like cutting tool consisted of a long curved blade and was known as a bill hook, an instrument typically used in agriculture. Alec was certain his property had once again fallen prey to burglars, but it wasn't until he came across Muriel's pet Daxand that he sensed something far more sinister had taken place. The small dog was resting on the living room floor in front of the large open fireplace, a crackling log fire blazed within. Muriel had previously lost two dogs in a fire and as a consequence always made sure that a protective screen was covering the fireplace whenever it was in use. On this occasion the screen was not up and Alec
接着，亚历克的目光被放在附近写字台上的一件异物吸引了。这把类似大砍刀的切割工具有一把长长的弯曲刀刃，被称为大镰刀（bill hook），通常用于农业。亚历克确信他的房子再次遭到了窃贼的光顾，但直到他看到穆丽尔的宠物腊肠犬时，他才感觉到发生了更加阴险的事情。这只小狗正趴在客厅的大开式壁炉前，里面燃着劈啪作响的木柴火。穆丽尔以前曾因火灾失去过两只狗，因此每当壁炉使用时，她总是确保用防护网将其罩住。这一次防护网并没有装上，亚历克
knew his wife would never leave the house without ensuring it was in place. Upon further inspection he also noticed the television was on, the shoes Muriel typically wore when heading out were neatly perched on the stairs and her car was in the garage. Fearing the intruder may still be in the house and Muriel might be hiding somewhere to protect herself. Alec armed himself with the bill hook and rushed upstairs to check the six bedrooms and two bathrooms, all the while calling out for his wife. When he found each room empty Alec checked the garage and the garden but to no avail. Muriel was gone. Alec hurried to a neighbour's house to raise the alarm and the police arrived to St Mary's house some 10 minutes later. They immediately noticed signs that someone outside
深知他的妻子绝不会在不确保防护网归位的情况下离开家。经过进一步检查，他还发现电视开着，穆丽尔出门时通常穿的鞋子整齐地放在楼梯上，她的车也停在车库里。由于担心入侵者可能还在屋里，而穆丽尔可能为了自保而躲在某处，亚历克拿起大镰刀冲上楼检查了六间卧室和两间浴室，一路上大声呼唤着妻子。当发现每个房间都空无一人时，亚历克又检查了车库和花园，但一无所获。穆丽尔不见了。亚历克匆忙跑到邻居家报警，大约 10 分钟后警察赶到了圣玛丽宅邸。他们立即注意到有迹象表明外面有人
had applied bodily pressure to the chained front door and forced their way in, an act which police determined only required light pushing. The disarranged state of the entrance hallway coupled with the presence of the adhesive tape, bailing twine and bill hook, none of which belonged to the Mackay's, painted a grim picture. An inventory revealed that Muriel's remaining jewellery was gone along with her fawn and black reversible coat, yet robbery seemed to be the perpetrator's secondary motive. It appeared as though Muriel Mackay had been abducted, the bill hook likely used to intimidate her as she was gagged with the adhesive tape and bound with the bailing twine. Alec described his wife as medium build, five foot nine inches tall with brown hair.
对挂着防盗链的前门施加了身体压力并强行闯入，警方判定这一举动只需轻轻推一下即可。门厅凌乱的状况，加上胶带、捆扎绳和不属于麦凯家的大镰刀的存在，勾勒出了一幅阴暗的画面。清点发现，穆丽尔剩下的珠宝不见了，她那件驼色和黑色两面穿的外交大衣也不见了，但抢劫似乎是作案者的次要动机。穆丽尔·麦凯似乎遭到了绑架，大镰刀很可能是用来恐吓她的，因为她被胶带封住了嘴并被捆扎绳捆绑了起来。亚历克形容他的妻子中等身材，身高五英尺九英寸，留着棕色头发。
He informed police that Muriel was her usual bright self that morning and had also prepared their dinner as though she was awaiting his arrival home. As officers canvassed the local area with tracking dogs, Muriel's family and friends were contacted, including her three adult children, Ian, Diane and Jennifer. No one could offer the names of anyone who might target the kind and gentle grandmother who was clearly beloved by those who knew her. Alec and Muriel were born and raised in Adelaide in South Australia and to the pair were childhood sweethearts. They married many years later as Alec was making a name for himself in advertising. After befriending members of the press elite, including Kerry Packer, Alec pursued a career in print media. Muriel was forever the
他告诉警方，穆丽尔那天早上和平时一样开朗，还准备了晚饭，就像是在等待他回家一样。当警官们带着搜救犬在当地挨家挨户搜寻时，穆丽尔的家属和朋友们也被联系上了，其中包括她的三个成年子女伊恩、黛安和詹妮弗。没有人能说出谁会把目标对准这位善良温和、深受熟悉她的人喜爱的祖母。亚历克和穆丽尔在南澳大利亚州的阿德莱德出生并长大，两人是青梅竹马的恋人。多年后，随着亚历克在广告界崭露头角，他们结为了夫妻。在结识了包括克里·帕克在内的报业精英后，亚历克投身于平面媒体行业。穆丽尔一直是那个
supportive wife, standing by her husband during their relocation to London and helping him network amongst publishing circles. In her spare time, Muriel indulged in her favorite hobby, painting, for which he had quite the talent. Desperate to raise awareness of his wife's disappearance, Alec Mackay sought help from his colleagues and friends in the press. He called the editor of News of the World Group newspaper The Sun, prompting throngs of journalists to descend on Arthur Road. Their presence frustrated police, who found the meddling media to be a distraction and liability. Five hours had passed since Muriel Mackay was reported missing and the Mackay property was still trawling with police officers, members of the press, and concerned friends and relatives.
支持丈夫的妻子，在他们搬迁到伦敦期间坚定地站在丈夫身旁，并帮助他在出版界建立人脉。在业余时间，穆丽尔沉迷于她最喜欢的爱好——绘画，她在这方面很有天赋。为了唤起人们对他妻子失踪的关注，亚历克·麦凯向他在新闻界的同事和朋友寻求帮助。他打电话给《世界新闻报》集团旗下报纸《太阳报》的编辑，引得大批记者蜂拥至亚瑟路。他们的存在让警方感到沮丧，警方发现这些爱管闲事的媒体不仅分散了精力，更是一个累赘。距离穆丽尔·麦凯被报失踪已经过去了五个小时，而麦凯的宅邸里依然挤满了警官、新闻界人士以及焦虑的亲朋好友。
The house phone had since been restored and reconnected when at 1.15am it suddenly rang. The Mackay son-in-law David answered as an unknown male voice asked, is that the home of Mr Mackay? To which David responded, who wants him? The caller explained, tell Mr Mackay it is the M3, the mafia. David handed the receiver to Alec as the caller went on. This is the mafia group 3, we are from America, mafia M3. We have your wife, you will need one million pounds by Wednesday, you would better get it. You have friends, get it from them. Have one million pounds by Wednesday night or we will kill her.
住宅里的电话此时已经修复并重新接通，就在凌晨 1 点 15 分，电话突然响了。麦凯的女婿大卫接了电话，一个陌生的男声问道：“这是麦凯先生的家吗？”大卫回答：“找他有什么事？”打电话的人解释说：“告诉麦凯先生，这是 M3，黑手党。”大卫把听筒递给了亚历克，电话那头继续说道：“这是黑手党第 3 组，我们来自美国，黑手党 M3。我们绑架了你的妻子，你星期三前需要准备好一百万英镑，你最好弄到手。你有很多朋友，从他们那儿去借。星期三晚上之前准备好一百万英镑，否则我们就杀了他。”
A detective listening in on an extension took note of the conversation, observing the caller had what sounded like a West Indian accent with hints of American overtones. This was confirmed by the call operator, who was still on the line ensuring the call connected. The operator informed authorities that the threatening call had been placed from a public telephone box in the suburb of Epping, 50km northeast of Wimbledon. Until the call from the mysterious M3 could be authenticated, police continued to treat Muriel's disappearance as a missing person's case. Although they didn't rule out the possibility of kidnapping, it seemed highly unlikely as such
一名在分机上监听的侦探记录下了这段对话，他注意到打电话的人听起来带有西印度口音，并隐约带有美国腔。这得到了仍在在线上确保通话连接的接线员的证实。接线员告知当局，这个威胁电话是从距离温布尔登东北 50 公里埃平（Epping）郊区的一个公用电话亭打出的。在神秘的 M3 打来的电话得到证实之前，警方继续将穆丽尔的失踪作为失踪人口案件处理。尽管他们没有排除绑架的可能性，但这似乎极不可能，因为
crimes were unheard of in Britain. When asked by a reporter if they were investigating a genuine ransom demand, the detective responded, how do we know? We've never had one before. Instead, a suspicious eye was cast towards Alec Mackay and even Muriel herself. Given the crime involved a newspaper executive who happened to oversee the country's two biggest tabloids, speculation arose as to whether the entire situation was a publicity stunt or hoax. The sensational story had gone straight to print with the attention-grabbing headline, Have You Seen This Woman? accompanied by a black and white photograph of a smiling Muriel. Articles speculated over the circumstances of her mysterious disappearance,
这种犯罪在英国闻所未闻。当被记者问及他们是否在调查一桩真实的勒索要求时，侦探回答：“我们怎么知道？我们以前从来没遇到过。”相反，怀疑的目光投向了亚历克·麦凯，甚至还有穆丽尔本人。鉴于这起犯罪涉及一位恰好监督该国两大小报的报业高管，外界开始猜测整个事件是否只是一场炒作或恶作剧。这则耸人听闻的故事直接被付诸印刷，并配上了吸引眼球的大标题：“你见过这个女人吗？”，旁边附有一张穆丽尔微笑的黑白照片。文章对她神秘失踪的情况进行了猜测，
with some crudely suggesting she may have left on her own accord in a fit of anger due to, quote, a menopausal incident. As the tabloid circulated salacious rumors, police focused their efforts on gathering the facts. Muriel's doctor assured she was in good health and was cheerful, stable and strong-minded at the time of her disappearance, giving no indications that she would want to leave her current circumstances. There were talks of a possible conflict between Muriel and Alec over a proposed trip to Australia, but it was more a disagreement than a dispute. Nationwide attention mounted, increasing pressure on police to solve the crime efficiently before it spawned a host of imitators. Despite law enforcement's apprehension
一些文章粗俗地暗示她可能是因为“更年期事件”而在一怒之下自愿离家出走的。当小报流传着各种下流的谣言时，警方则将精力集中在收集事实上。穆丽尔的医生向警方保证，她在失踪时身体健康，开朗、情绪稳定且意志坚强，没有任何迹象表明她会想要离开目前的生活环境。有传言称穆丽尔和亚历克曾因去澳大利亚的计划发生过冲突，但这更像是一次意见不合，而不是激烈的争吵。全国各地的关注度不断上升，给警方施加了巨大的压力，迫使其必须高效破案，以免滋生出一批模仿犯。尽管执法部门对
to involve the media, on Tuesday, December 30, the day after Muriel vanished, her grief-stricken daughter Diane appeared on national television to compel anyone with information to come forward. Just before five o'clock that evening, another phone call was placed to the Makai household from M3, the unknown man alleging to have taken Muriel. The call was untraceable, leading investigators to assume the professed kidnapper was now using the automatic system known as subscriber trunk dialing, which allowed calls to be made without operator assistance. The police had since attached a tape recorder to the Makai's phone line, enabling them to document M3's voice as he told Alec. Your wife just posted a letter to you. For heaven's sake,
卷入媒体心存顾虑，但在 12 月 30 日星期二，即穆丽尔失踪的第二天，她悲痛欲绝的女儿黛安出现在全国电视节目中，呼吁任何掌握线索的人站出来。就在当晚近五点钟时，麦凯家中又接到了一个来自 M3 的电话，这个自称绑架了穆丽尔的陌生男子再次打来。该电话无法追踪，导致调查人员推测这位自称绑架者的人现在使用的是被称为用户字干拨号（subscriber trunk dialing）的自动系统，该系统允许在没有接线员协助的情况下拨打电话。此后，警方在麦凯家的电话线上安装了一台录音机，以便在 M3 告诉亚历克时记录下他的声音：“你妻子刚刚给你寄了一封信。看在上帝的份上，
for her sake, don't call the police. The following day of Wednesday, December 31, a letter arrived to the Makai household as forecast. Its envelope was marked urgent and contained a piece of cheap blue paper with messy handwriting scrawled in sloping lines across the page. The handwriting was identified to be without doubt that of Muriel Makai, confirming M3 had direct contact with the missing woman. The letter read, Alec darling, I am blindfolded and cold. Please do something and get me home. Please cooperate or I cannot keep going. I think of you all constantly and have kept calm so far. What have I done to deserve this treatment?
看在她的份上，千万别报警。”第二天，即 12 月 31 日星期三，正如预料的那样，一封信送达了麦凯家中。信封上标有“紧急”字样，里面装有一张廉价的蓝纸，上面用倾斜的线条潦草地写着凌乱的字迹。经辨认，这无疑是穆丽尔·麦凯的笔迹，这证实了 M3 与失踪妇女有过直接接触。信中写道：“亲爱的亚历克，我被蒙上双眼，感到很冷。请做点什么把我接回家。请配合，否则我撑不下去了。我无时无刻不在想念你，到目前为止我一直保持着冷静。我做错了什么，要遭受这种对待？”
Postage stamps indicated the letter had been sent from Tottenham, a suburb 30 kilometers northeast of Wimbledon. As the original phone call from M3 had been traced to Wepping, investigators now believed the kidnapper and possibly Muriel were located within the north easterly outskirts of London. Upon the receival of Muriel's letter, police officially shifted their missing person search into a kidnapping for ransom investigation. As cities across the world celebrated the new year, Muriel Makai's family sat anxiously by the phone awaiting further instructions from M3. Overwhelmed by the uncertain fate of his wife, Alec Makai was sedated to allow him some much needed rest. Shortly before 7.45 pm on New Year's Eve,
邮票显示这封信是从托特纳姆（Tottenham）寄出的，那是温布尔登东北 30 公里处的一个郊区。由于 M3 最初的电话被追踪到埃平（Wepping），调查人员现在认为绑架者以及穆丽尔可能位于伦敦的东北部市郊。收到穆丽尔的信后，警方正式将寻人失踪案转为绑架勒索案调查。正当世界各地的城市庆祝新年之际，穆丽尔·麦凯的家人焦虑地坐在电话旁，等待 M3 的进一步指示。由于无法承受妻子未卜生死的打击，亚历克·麦凯被注射了镇静剂，以便让他得到急需的休息。新年夜晚上 7 点 45 分前不久，
the mysterious caller rang once again, this time asking to speak to Muriel's daughter Diane. He told her, try and remember the M3. I wanted to speak to your daddy. He's not well. Where is your mother? Do you have any idea? You've gone too far. It has gone too far now. M3 abruptly ended this call, only to ring again a few minutes later, demanding to speak to Diane once more. This time he told her, they've got to get a million in tenors and fivers. Muriel's son Ian took the receiver from his sister and asked how they were expected to raise such a large sum of money in such a short amount of time. The caller responded, that's your business, not mine. While police aimed to keep the letter from Muriel classified,
神秘的打电话者再次打来电话，这次要求与穆丽尔的女儿黛安通话。他对她说：“试着记住 M3。我想和你爸爸谈谈。他身体不好。你母亲在哪？你有一点线索吗？你们太过分了。现在事情已经闹得太过了。”M3 突然挂断了电话，但在几分钟后又打了过来，再次要求与黛安通话。这一次他告诉她：“他们必须准备好一百万，全部用十镑和五镑的纸币。”穆丽尔的儿子伊恩从姐姐手中接过听筒，问他们怎么可能在这么短的时间内筹集到这么大一笔钱。打电话的人回答说：“那是你们的事，不是我的。”虽然警方试图对穆丽尔的信件内容保密，
its contents were soon leaked to the press, resulting in a bombardment of Hope's calls and mail from opportunists hoping to cash in on the Makai family's desperate situation. Audio recordings of the kidnapper's voice and the fact he used the alias M3 helped investigators filter out some of the false leads. Undercover police officers and criminal informants were told to listen out for whispers about the identity or history of the enigmatic group Mafia 3, while anonymous tips sent investigators all over the city. One claimed Muriel was in a tunnel underneath a church near the Makai home, but when police arrived to the location, they discovered the passage had been sealed up years
但其内容很快泄露给媒体，导致麦凯家人陷入绝境之际，大批投机取巧者打来诈骗电话并寄来信件。绑架者的声音录音以及他使用 M3 这个化名的事实，帮助调查人员过滤掉了一些虚假线索。便衣警察和刑事线索提供人被告知要留意有关神秘组织“黑手党 3”身份或历史的蛛丝马迹，而匿名举报则让调查人员在全城奔波。有人声称穆丽尔被关在麦凯家附近一座教堂底下的隧道里，但当警察赶到现场时，发现该通道多年前就已经被封死了。另一个电话来自一个女人，她神秘兮兮地说了“格雷·希尔曼（Gray Hillman）”几个字，然后就挂断了。希尔曼是一款小型英国汽车，未经证实的媒体报道信誓旦旦地称，这个电话是穆丽尔本人打的，试图为警方提供一条线索。
ago. Another call came through from a woman who ominously said the words Gray Hillman before hanging up. A Hillman is a small British car, and unsubstantiated media reports boldly claimed this call was from Muriel herself, attempting to provide police with a clue. Hundreds of statements were collected from members of the public, including one from a Wimbledon local who recalled seeing a dark-colored Volvo saloon-style car with two male occupants slowly cruising the Arthur Road area at 4.40pm on the day Muriel went missing. That same evening, at around 6pm, a neighbour noticed all the interior lights at the Makai home were on, and a dark saloon car was parked in their driveway.
公众提供了数百份陈述，其中包括一名温布尔登当地人的回忆：在穆丽尔失踪当天下午 4 点 40 分，他看到一辆深色的沃尔沃轿车，车内有两名男子，正缓慢地在亚瑟路地区巡视。当晚 6 点左右，一名邻居注意到麦凯家的室内灯全亮着，一辆深色轿车停在他们的车道上。正当麦凯一家绝望地等待穆丽尔绑架者的进一步联系时，一位家族朋友联系了颇具争议的荷兰明眼人（clairvoyant）杰拉德·克拉泽（Gerard Kraze），他因协助警方追踪失踪人口而声誉鹊起。
As the Makais waited desperately for further contact from Muriel's kidnapper, a family friend reached out to controversial Dutch clairvoyant Gerard Kraze, who had developed a reputation for helping police trace missing persons. Kraze had been asked to assist in many investigations, including the disappearance of young siblings Jane, Anna and Grant Beaumont from a South Australian beach just three years earlier, covered in episode 100 of Case File. Yet, as his work on the Beaumont Children case revealed, Kraze's authenticated success rate was negligible. Nevertheless, Muriel Makai's kidnapping had become a media sensation, and Gerard Kraze's opinions were soon headlining news reports.
克拉泽曾被邀请协助许多调查，其中包括三年前南澳大利亚海滩上年轻兄妹简、安娜和格兰特·博蒙特（Jane, Anna and Grant Beaumont）的失踪案，该案在《案件档案》（Case File）第 100 期中有所报道。然而，正如他在博蒙特儿童案中的工作所表明的那样，克拉泽被证实的成功率微乎其微。尽管如此，穆丽尔·麦凯的绑架案已经演变成一场媒体轰动，杰拉德·克拉泽的看法很快成为新闻头条。
During one interview, a reporter sat on the edge of their seat as Kraze rubbed his hand over a photograph of Muriel and observed a map of London before matter of factually announcing that she was still alive. He claimed she was being held on a white farm northeast of London, near a disused aerodome on a tree-lined property with a green barn and a pond that contained an old motorcycle. The clairvoyant menacingly added that if Muriel was not found within 14 days, she would be dead. Suddenly, Muriel's abduction became an exciting ticking time bomb for the media, with reports calculating how long she could survive in the current cold climate if she wasn't being properly cared for. Kraze's visions were not particularly extraordinary,
在一次采访中，一名记者正襟危坐，而克拉泽则将手在一张穆丽尔的照片上揉搓，并观察着伦敦的地图，随后斩钉截铁地宣布她还活着。他声称她被关押在伦敦东北部的一个白色农场里，靠近一个废弃的飞机场，那是一个绿树成荫的庄园，里面有一个绿色谷仓和一个池塘，池塘里有一辆旧摩托车。这位有特异功能的人带有威胁意味地补充说，如果在 14 天内找不到穆丽尔，她就会死。突然之间，穆丽尔的绑架案成了媒体眼中一个令人兴奋的倒计时炸弹，各种报道计算着如果她得不到适当的照顾，她在当前的寒冷气候下能存活多久。克拉泽的预言并不是特别非凡，
as they matched the insights already provided to British police by specialist agents from the FBI who worked as consultants to the detectives overseeing the Muriel Makai investigation. They would prove an invaluable resource, as unlike Britain, the US had dealt with many high-profile ransom cases in the preceding decades, including that of one-month-old Peter Weinberger, covered in episode 64 of Casefire. Given that it was believed Muriel's kidnapper was located in the northeastern suburbs of London, coupled with the FBI's advice that Muriel was likely being held somewhere remote like a rural farmhouse, hundreds of police officers and volunteers descended on ebbing forest and at surrounds, trudging the damp brush, whilst divers searched
因为它们与联邦调查局（FBI）的专家特工先前提供给英国警察的见解相吻合，这些特工曾担任监督穆丽尔·麦凯案的侦探的顾问。事实证明，这是一笔宝贵的财富，因为与英国不同，美国在过去的几十年里处理过许多高调的勒索案件，其中包括一个月大的彼得·温伯格（Peter Weinberger）案，该案在《案件档案》第 64 期中有所报道。鉴于人们认为穆丽尔的绑架者位于伦敦东北郊，再加上 FBI 的建议，即穆丽尔可能被关押在像乡村农场这样偏远的地方，数百名警察和志愿者涌入埃平森林及周边地区，跋涉在潮湿的灌木丛中，而潜水员则搜寻了附近的池塘和河流。
nearby ponds and rivers. They were tailed by members of the public who were following the visions offered by Gerard Kraze. Yet, the only area of interest found was an abandoned farm, which was investigated and promptly ruled out. Kraze's intervention became a source of contention for investigators, with one detective remarking, because of Kraze, we wasted thousands of man hours, not through following up his ideas, but because of all the imitators. Meanwhile, Alec Makai agreed to be formally interviewed for television news, during which he described coming home on the evening of December 29 to find his house in disarray and his wife missing. He addressed speculation that Muriel had left on her own accord, stating,
他们身后尾随着根据杰拉德·克拉泽提供的预言进行寻找的公众。然而，唯一被发现的感兴趣区域是一座废弃的农场，经过调查后很快被排除。克拉泽的介入成了调查人员争论的焦点，一位侦探评论道：“因为克拉泽，我们浪费了数千个工时，倒不是因为去跟进他的想法，而是因为那些蜂拥而至的模仿者。”与此同时，亚历克·麦凯同意接受电视新闻的正式采访，在采访中他描述了自己在 12 月 29 日傍晚回家时发现房子一片混乱、妻子失踪的情景。他回应了关于穆丽尔是自愿离家出走的猜测，并表示：
Now, I think no man in the world would say that his wife wouldn't leave him. I really believe that she wouldn't leave me. He concluded the interview by remarking, Well, I have spent a considerable time under sedation, but as this has been lessened off a bit, of course, I am terribly worried. I am frantic that I can get my wife back again. What can I do? I'm only asking the cooperation of everybody who may be watching, who may be listening, or may be reading, to please help us to get her back again. It's merely a question of her sitting and waiting by the telephone, is it? Yes, and that's a very long wait.
“现在，我想世上没有任何男人会说自己的妻子绝不会离开他。但我真的相信她不会离开我。”他以这样一番话结束了采访：“好吧，我在镇静剂的作用下度过了相当长的时间，但随着药效略有减退，我当然非常担心。我急切地想要找回我的妻子。我能做什么？我只是恳求所有可能在看、在听或在读的人，请帮帮我们把她找回来。”“这仅仅是一个人坐在电话旁等待的问题，对吗？”“是的，这是一个非常漫长的等待。”
Alec's emotional appeal proved futile in re-establishing contact with M3, prompting detectives to employ more cunning tactics. They asked the Makai family doctor to front the press with a fabricated story that Muriel suffered a medical condition that required treatment with three injections per month. The doctor went along with the lie, telling a crowd of reporters that Muriel's well-being was in very serious danger, and expressed false urgency about her need for medication. Despite these efforts, Muriel's kidnapper remained silent. The next appeal came from Muriel's three children.
亚历克的情感呼吁在重新建立与 M3 的联系方面被证明是徒劳的，这促使侦探们采取了更狡猾的战术。他们请麦凯一家的家庭医生出面向媒体发表虚假报道，称穆丽尔患有一种需要每月注射三次药物的宿疾。医生配合了这个谎言，对一群记者说穆丽尔的健康状况处于极其危险的境地，并对她对药物的需求表现出了虚假的紧迫感。尽管作出了这些努力，穆丽尔的绑架者依然保持沉默。接下来的呼吁来自穆丽尔的三个孩子。
Ayan, Jennifer, and Diane fronted the news cameras together as Ayan read a statement on behalf of their father. The statement from Mr Makai says, would you please inform me what I have to do to get my wife back? What do you want from me? I'm willing to do anything within reason to get my wife back. Please give me your instructions and what guarantee I have that she will be safely returned to me. I have had so many persons communicate with me that I must be certain that I'm dealing with the right person. The hysteria arising from Britain's first high-profile kidnapping for ransom generated a myriad of false sightings, irrelevant tips, prank calls, and phony demands. One fraudster demanding a ransom met with undercover police
伊恩、詹妮弗和黛安一同出现在新闻镜头前，由伊恩代他们的父亲宣读了一份声明。麦凯先生的声明说：“请告诉我，为了找回我的妻子，我必须做些什么？你们从我这里想要什么？为了找回我的妻子，我愿意做任何合乎情理的事情。请给我指示，以及我如何能确保她安全归还的保证。有这么多人与我联系，我必须确保我是在和正确的人打交道。”英国第一起引人注目的绑架勒索案引发的歇斯底里，产生了无数虚假的目击事件、无关紧要的线索、恶作剧电话和虚假勒索。一名要求勒索的骗子在伦敦东部的地铁站与便衣警察会面，
in an east London underground train station and was later jailed for three years for the deception. Eight days after the last call from M3, the news of the world editor Stafford Somerville received a letter from the kidnapper marked urgent and personal. In handwritten capital letters on white lined paper torn from an exercise book, M3 complained he was unable to contact Alec Makai as the phone line was busy. He stated he would only provide instructions on how to secure Muriel's release once the police were sent away. The kidnapper suggested the million pound ransom be handed over in two installments of half a million each, adding, if he cooperates he shall see his wife, if he don't cooperate his wife will be disposed of.
后因欺诈罪被判处三年监禁。在 M3 打来最后一个电话的八天后，《世界新闻报》编辑斯塔福德·萨默维尔（Stafford Somerville）收到了一封来自绑架者的信，信封上标有“紧急且私人”字样。M3 用手写的大写字母写在从练习本上撕下的白色有行白纸上，抱怨由于电话线一直占线，他无法联系到麦凯先生。他表示，只有在警察撤走后，他才会提供如何确保穆丽尔获释的指示。绑架者建议将一百万英镑的赎金分两次支付，每次五十万，并补充说：“如果他配合，他就会见到他的妻子；如果不配合，他的妻子将被处决。”
The letter ended with, he has not paid off for St Mary's house and she said he hasn't the money, but he can borrow from friends he knows. Four days of silence followed, ending on Wednesday, January 14, when Stafford Somerville received a phone call from M3, reiterating his demands and ordering the newspaper editor to tell Mr Makai that he would prove that Muriel was still alive. Later that day, M3 rang the Makai household and provided the family with what he deemed to be proof that Muriel was still alive, detailing the fact she was wearing her fawn and black coat. The Makai's were unconvinced this information proved anything, so M3 said Muriel would write them another letter.
信的结尾是：“他还没有付清圣玛丽宅邸的房款，她说他没有这笔钱，但他可以向认识的朋友借。”随后是四天的沉默，直到 1 月 14 日星期三结束，当时斯塔福德·萨默维尔接到了 M3 打来的电话，重申了他的要求，并命令这位报纸编辑告诉麦凯先生，他会证明穆丽尔还活着。当天晚些时候，M3 打电话到麦凯家，向家人提供了他认为可以证明穆丽尔还活着的证据，详细描述了她穿着那件驼色和黑色外套的事实。麦凯一家并不相信这些信息能证明什么，于是 M3 说穆丽尔会给他们写另一封信。
The next call to the Makai residence came five days later on Monday, January 19. Shortly before 3pm, Alec Makai answered the phone and was greeted by M3 who said, Hello Alec, we contacted you last week concerning Muriel. A 35 minute conversation followed, the longest from Muriel's kidnapper to date, wherein he claimed to have infiltrated the UK's criminal investigation department to ensure the case would never be solved. Alec pressed for proof that his wife was still alive, suggesting that in her next letter Muriel should write out the full names of their children, or provide details of the Christmas present she had recently received.
五天后的 1 月 19 日星期一，麦凯住宅迎来了下一个电话。下午 3 点前不久，亚历克·麦凯接了电话，M3 向他打招呼说：“喂，亚历克，我们上周就穆丽尔的事联系过你。”随后进行了长达 35 分钟的对话，这是穆丽尔的绑架者迄今为止最长的一次通话，他在通话中声称自己已经渗入了英国的刑事调查部，以确保此案永远不会被破获。亚历克坚决要求提供他妻子还活着的证据，并建议穆丽尔在下一封信中写出他们孩子的全名，或者提供她最近收到的圣诞礼物的细节。
M3 disregarded this request, reassuring Alec that Muriel was alive and he would be able to speak to her as soon as the first delivery of ransom money was made. He stated, You are to be blamed for going to the police. We are looking for a place where you should meet us to bring the money. Anguished Alec responded, Look, bring a gun here and shoot me rather than ask unreasonable demands. Nobody's got a million pounds, I can't give you what I haven't got. When asked what he did to deserve this Alec was told, I don't know, but your wife is such a nice person. M3 further explained, This is not one person, this is worldwide, international. I run this branch in England, you see. Don't take any telephone calls from anyone
M3 忽视了这个请求，向亚历克保证穆丽尔还活着，只要支付第一笔赎金，他就能和她通话。他说道：“去找警察是你的错。我们在找一个地方，你得去那里见我们带钱。”痛苦的亚历克回答道：“听着，带把枪来这里把我枪毙了吧，也别提这些不合理的要求。没有人有一百万英镑，我拿不出我没有的东西。”当被问及他做错了什么要遭受这一切时，得到的回答是：“我不知道，但你的妻子是个这么好的人。”M3 进一步解释说：“这不是一个人，这是全球性的，国际化的。你看，我在英国经营这个分部。”“不要接听任何人的电话，
unless they say M3. The mafia, M3. He then rambled on about a group he referred to simply as the boys who had tailed Rupert Murdoch's Rolls Royce with the intention of kidnapping the wealthy media mogul's wife Anna. However, as the Murdochs were on holiday in Australia, the boys inadvertently followed their Rolls Royce to the Mackay residents and abducted the wrong woman in a case of mistaken identity. Despite now dealing with someone who had significantly less net worth than their original target, M3 continued to demand the exorbitant £1 million ransom from Alec Mackay. When Alec offered the far more attainable sum of £20,000, M3 replied, Over here, no use. Accept or reject, half a million. You gotta do something about it. Dejected, Alec replied. I could kill myself,
除非他们说 M3。黑手党，M3。”然后他开始胡言乱语地谈论一个他简称为“这帮小子”的团伙，他们曾尾随鲁珀特·默多克的劳斯莱斯汽车，企图绑架这位富有的媒体大亨的妻子安娜。然而，由于默多克夫妇当时正在澳大利亚度假，这帮小子无意中跟着他们的劳斯莱斯来到了麦凯的住所，并在认错人的情况下绑架了错误的女人。尽管现在打交道的人身价远低于他们最初的目标，但 M3 仍然向亚历克·麦凯勒索高达 100 万英镑的天价赎金。当亚历克提出两万英镑这个容易得多、更能实现的金额时，M3 回答说：“在这里没用。接受或拒绝，五十万。你必须采取行动。”沮丧的亚历克回答说：“我可以自杀，
that would solve the problem. As the call reached its conclusion, M3 stated, My taxi is waiting. I've got to go to the airport to receive one of the boys. You've got to get half a million. This is my order, and that is final. The next call from M3 came through two days later on Wednesday, January 21, and was answered by Alec and Muriel's son, Ian. M3 advised Ian he would be sending an envelope containing two letters from Muriel, one addressed to Alec and another to their daughter, Diane, that proved Muriel was still alive. According to M3, she was trying to tell you all where she was, so we had to clip a few pieces off. M3 ended the call, but rang again a few
那就能解决问题了。”随着通话接近尾声，M3 说道：“我的出租车在等我。我得去机场接这帮小子中的一个。你必须弄到五十万。这是我的命令，就这样定了。”M3 的下一个电话在两天后的 1 月 21 日星期三打来，由亚历克和穆丽尔的儿子伊恩接听。M3 通知伊恩，他将寄出一个信封，里面装有穆丽尔的两封信，一封写给亚历克，另一封写给他们的女儿黛安，以证明穆丽尔还活着。据 M3 说，她试图告诉大家她在哪里，所以我们不得不割掉了几个零件。M3 挂断了电话，但在几分钟后又打来，
minutes later to arrange the first ransom drop. Advising Ian the half a million pound payment would grant the Makai's phone contact with Muriel. Ian informed the kidnapper that his father was far too ill to participate in the ransom drop, and that he would do it instead. In actuality, concerns they might be dealing with an international criminal gang meant police were prioritising Alec Makai's safety, denying him any direct contact with Muriel's captors. The following day of Friday, January 22, two letters from Muriel arrived to the Makai house in a single envelope, just as M3 had described. A postage stamp specified the letter had been sent from Wood Green, another suburb in London's northeast. Both letters were undoubtedly written
安排第一次赎金交接。M3 告诉伊恩，支付五十万英镑将使麦凯一家能够与穆丽尔通电话。伊恩通知绑架者，他的父亲病情太重，无法参与赎金交接，将由他代劳。事实上，担心他们可能在与一个国际犯罪团伙打交道，意味着警方将亚历克·麦凯的安全放在首位，拒绝让他与穆丽尔的绑架者进行任何直接接触。第二天，即 1 月 22 日星期五，正如 M3 所描述的那样，穆丽尔的两封信在一个信封里送达了麦凯家。邮票表明这封信是从伍德格林（Wood Green）寄出的，这是伦敦东北部的另一个郊区。这两封信无疑都是用
in Muriel's handwriting. In the one penned for her husband, Muriel wrote, Dear Alec, I am deteriorating in health and spirit. Please cooperate. Excuse writing, I am blindfolded and cold. The earlier you get the money, the quicker I may come home, or you may not see me again, darling. Negotiate with gang as quickly as possible. The gang is too large to fool. In the letter to her daughter Diane, Muriel wrote, I heard you on TV. If only you would persuade daddy to cooperate with the gang. Please keep the police out of it if you want to see me. It was this comment that raised concerns about Muriel's well-being. Although Diane had appeared on national television multiple times throughout her mother's disappearance,
穆丽尔的笔迹写的。在写给丈夫的那封信中，穆丽尔写道：“亲爱的亚历克，我的健康和精神都在恶化。请配合。请原谅我的字迹，我被蒙上双眼，而且很冷。你越快拿到钱，我就能越快回家，否则亲爱的你可能再也见不到我了。尽快与帮派谈判。这个帮派太庞大了，无法愚弄。”在写给女儿黛安的信中，穆丽尔写道：“我在电视上听到你的声音了。如果你能说服爸爸与这个帮派合作就好了。如果你想再见到我，请别让警察插手。”正是这句话引起了人们对穆丽尔健康状况的担忧。尽管黛安在母亲失踪期间多次出现在全国电视上，
she only ever spoke once. During a news report that aired on the BBC on December 30, the day after Muriel was taken. For Muriel to specifically mention this appearance 23 days later seemed highly unusual. Detectives now suspected she may have been forced to pen all the letters to her family at a much earlier date, with her kidnapper sending them intermittently to give the illusion they were being written throughout the course of the investigation. For the first time since her disappearance, police were confronted with the possibility that Muriel Makai was dead, and that her killer was planning his moves in advance to foster the hope she was alive. Ensuring he maintained control over the situation.
但她只说过一次话。在 12 月 30 日（穆丽尔被绑架的第二天）在英国广播公司（BBC）播出的新闻报道中。穆丽尔在 23 天后专门提到这次出镜，显得很不寻常。侦探们现在怀疑她可能在很早的时候就被迫给家人写了所有的信，而她的绑架者则断断续续地寄出这些信，以营造出这些信是在整个调查过程中一直在写的假象。自她失踪以来，警方第一次面对这样一种可能性：穆丽尔·麦凯已经遇害，而她的凶手正在提前策划每一步，以维持她还活着的希望，从而确保他对局势的控制。
Also enclosed with Muriel's two recent letters was a note from M3 providing instructions for the first ransom drop which was to take place in 10 days time on the 1st of February. Half a million pounds was to be placed in a locked black suitcase and driven in Muriel's board Capri along North Circular Road to the public phone box at the Cambridge Road and Church Street intersection. M3 would ring the phone box at exactly 10pm to provide the next set of instructions. According to M3, the suitcase would be collected by a random stranger who was being paid to retrieve it. Therefore, if this person wound up in police custody, they would not be able to provide information about M3 or Muriel's whereabouts. The letter ended, quote,
与穆丽尔最近的两封信一起寄来的还有 M3 的一张便条，上面提供了第一次赎金交接的指示，交接将在 10 天后的 2 月 1 日进行。五十万英镑必须放入一个加锁的黑色手提箱中，并用穆丽尔的福特卡普里车沿着北环路（North Circular Road）运送到剑桥路和教堂街交叉口的公用电话亭。M3 将在晚上正好 10 点拨打这个电话亭，以提供下一组指示。据 M3 说，手提箱将由一个被花钱雇来取走它的随机陌生人取走。因此，如果这个人落入警方手中，他也无法提供关于 M3 或穆丽尔下落的信息。信的结尾是，引述如下：
any error on your part will only take two minutes and you will never see Muriel again. You will see her dead and delivered at your door. The day after the ransom note arrived, Muriel's kidnapper resumed his menacing phone calls to the Mackay household. Pressing for proof his mother was still alive, Ian asked M3. The letters could have been written weeks ago. Why the hell should we give you the money unless we know she's alive? An argument broke out between the pair as to whether a description of the clothing Muriel was wearing when she disappeared was proof of her living status. Ian pointed out that the police and the press had described Muriel's outfit from the outset of the investigation,
“你们方面的任何错误只需要两分钟，你们就再也见不到穆丽尔了。你们会看到她的尸体被送到你们家门口。”在赎金便条到达的第二天，穆丽尔的绑架者恢复了对麦凯家令人毛骨悚然的电话骚扰。为了逼问他母亲是否还活着的证据，伊恩质问 M3：“这些信可能是几周前写的。除非我们知道她还活着，否则我们凭什么把钱给你？”两人就是否用穆丽尔失踪时穿的衣服的描述来作为她生存状态的证据展开了争论。伊恩指出，警方和媒体从调查一开始就描述了穆丽尔的衣着，
therefore repeating this well-known information proved nothing. Ian asked to speak to his mother or to have a tape recording of her speaking be sent to their family. But M3 ignored his request and ended the call. Less than two hours later, M3 was back on the phone, telling Ian, I've just contacted head office and this is final. If you don't intend to cooperate, we shall drop the matter there. We won't be needing the money and you won't be seeing your mum. Ian explained they had gathered a quarter of a million pounds but before M3 saw a scent, they needed proof Muriel was alive. His request was again denied, leading Ian to snap. It's because you haven't got her. You've got a corpse. You're trying to trick us.
因此重复这些众所周知的信息并不能证明任何问题。伊恩要求与他的母亲说话，或者要求将她说话的录音寄给他们的家人。但 M3 忽视了他的请求并挂断了电话。不到两个小时后，M3 又打来电话，对伊恩说：“我刚联系了总部，这是最后的决定。如果你们不打算合作，我们就此罢休。我们不需要钱，你也见不到你妈妈了。”伊恩解释说他们已经筹集了二十五万英镑，但在 M3 看到哪怕一分钱之前，他们需要穆丽尔还活着的证据。他的请求再次被拒绝，导致伊恩勃然大怒：“那是因为你根本没有她。你只有一具尸体。你是在试图欺骗我们。”
Before ending this call M3 explained, we've never murdered anyone as yet, but there's always got to be a first time. Prompting Ian to retort. Okay then, but you get no money. In an attempt to reassure them Akai's M3 told them we deal with honesty. 15 minutes later M3 called again, telling Ian, your mum said she has been a good wife to your dad and a good mother to her children. She asked why have they forsaken her. If you want your mum, follow instructions. Exasperated, Ian requested the kidnapper purchase a copy of that night's evening standard newspaper and have Muriel write out the headlines to prove without doubt that she was indeed alive.
在结束这通电话之前，M3解释道，我们目前还没杀过人，但总有第一次。这促使伊恩反驳道，好吧，但你们拿不到钱。为了安抚他们，阿凯的M3告诉他们，我们做生意讲究诚实。15 minutes later M3 called again, telling Ian, your mum said she has been a good wife to your dad and a good mother to her children. She asked why have they forsaken her. If you want your mum, follow instructions. Exasperated, Ian requested the kidnapper purchase a copy of that night's evening standard newspaper and have Muriel write out the headlines to prove without doubt that she was indeed alive.
Three days later, on Monday, January 26, an envelope addressed to Alec Mackay arrived to St Mary's house. Its postage stamp confirmed it too was sent from Wood Green. Inside, there were two handwritten letters from Muriel, but neither contained the list of newspaper headlines requested by Ian. Instead, the first letter read, Alec darling, if I could only be home, I can't believe this thing has happened to me. Tonight I thought I'd see you, but it seems hopeless. That is all I can say at the moment. He betrayed me by going to police, not cooperating with M3 gang. Love, Muriel.
三天后的1月26日星期一，一个写有亚历克·麦凯收的信封送到了圣玛丽宅邸。其上面的邮票证实，它同样是从伍德格林寄出的。里面有莫丽尔手写的两封信，但两封信都没有包含伊恩要求的报纸头条清单。相反，第一封信写道，亲爱的亚历克，我要是能回家就好了，真不敢相信这种事会发生在我身上。今晚我以为能见到你，但看起来希望渺茫。目前我只能说这么多了。他通过报警背叛了我，没有配合M3帮派。爱你的，莫丽尔。
The second letter was shorter, stating, darling Alec, you don't seem to be helping me. Again, I beg of you to cooperate with the M3 gang. The bottom section of this page had been removed, likely done by M3 who had previously claimed to cut out any section of Muriel's letters that could reveal her whereabouts. Her unfinished final message read, you understand that when there, the envelope also contained another note from Muriel's kidnapper, which read, I am sending you final letter for your wife's reprieve. She will be executed on February 2nd, 1970, unless you keep our business date on February 1st without any error.
第二封信较短，上面写着，亲爱的亚历克，你好像没在帮我。我再次恳请你配合M3帮派。这页纸的底部已被撕掉，很可能是M3干的，他曾声称会剪掉莫丽尔信中任何可能暴露她下落的部分。她未写完的最后一条信息写道，你知道当信封里还包含来自莫丽尔绑架者的另一张便条时，上面写着，我正在给你寄去关于你妻子暂缓执行死刑的最后一封信。她将于1970年2月2日被处决，除非你毫无差错地遵守我们在2月1日的商业约会。
We demand the full million pound in two occasions. When you deliver the first half million, your wife's life will be saved and I personally shall allow her to speak to you on the telephone. This is our fourth blackmail. We have absorbed three and a half million pounds. We did not murder anyone because they were wise to pay up and their family were returned to them. You do the same and she will return safely. Looking forward to settling our business on the 1st of February at 10pm as stated on last letter in a very discreet and honest way. You and your children will be happy to join Muriel Mackay and our organization also will be happy to continue our job elsewhere. That is why we won't accept Ian telling us what to do.
We give the order and you must obey. Also enclosed within the envelope were three small squares of material, green woollen fabric, fawn and black reversible fabric and cream colored leather. All neatly cut from the clothing Muriel was wearing the day she vanished. Two days before the scheduled ransom drop, Muriel's kidnapper was on the telephone to Ian Mackay again, warning any error will be fatal. Although M3 originally ordered the cash to be delivered using Muriel's car, Ian proposed using the chaufford Rolls Royce instead as he was unable to drive due to a recent injury that put his arm in a sling. M3 raised no objections, unaware that Ian's story was a lie. Police had
我们下达命令，你必须服从。信封里还附有三小块布料：一块绿色羊绒面料、一块黄褐色与黑色双面面料以及一块乳白色皮革。它们都是从莫丽尔失踪当天所穿的衣服上整齐剪下来的。在预定的赎金交接日前两天，莫丽尔的绑架者再次给伊恩·麦凯打去了电话，警告任何错误都将是致命的。尽管M3最初命令使用莫丽尔的车来运送现金，但由于伊恩最近受伤导致手臂打着石膏而无法开车，他遂提议改用带司机的劳斯莱斯。M3没有提出异议，他并不知道伊恩的说法是个谎言。警方
crafted the tactic to enable two people to be in the Rolls Royce which had an inbuilt telecommunications set. On Sunday February 1, M3 telephoned Ian to say he would see his mother again if everything went smoothly that night. It seemed the kidnapper had finally conceded that he would never receive the full £1 million ransom and was now willing to release Muriel for half the original amount. He ordered Ian to guarantee that Muriel would not be interrogated by the press or police upon her return to her family. At 9pm, the Rolls Royce pulled away from St Mary's house, driven by undercover Detective Inspector John Miners acting as the chauffeur, complete with uniform. Treating the situation with utmost care and diligence, Detective Miners had taken the
精心设计了一个战术，以便让两个人坐在配有内置通信设备的劳斯莱斯里。2月1日星期日，M3给伊恩打电话说，如果今晚一切顺利，他将再次见到他的母亲。看来绑架者终于承认他永远拿不到全部100万英镑的赎金了，现在愿意用原来的一半金额释放莫丽尔。他命令伊恩保证，莫丽尔在回到家人身边后不会受到媒体或警察的审问。晚上9点，这辆劳斯莱斯驶离了圣玛丽宅邸，由身穿制服、扮成司机的便衣探长约翰·迈纳斯（John Miners）驾驶。迈纳斯探长以极大的细心和勤勉对待这一情况，他花
time to learn how to drive the Rolls Royce just like the chauffeur. Detective Sergeant Roger Street was in the back seat, his hair dyed and restyled to closer resemble Ian Mackay. His arm was secured in a sling to indicate it was injured, but actually served to conceal a two-way radio. The detectives were in possession of a black suitcase containing half a million pounds, made up of several bundles of fake banknotes with a thin layer of genuine money on top. An electronic homing device was also inside. As per M3's directions, the Rolls Royce drove along North Circular Road towards the A-10 motorway where it pulled up to the public telephone box at the Cambridge Road and Church Street intersection. Detective Street, posing as Ian, exited the
时间学会了像司机一样驾驶劳斯莱斯。罗杰·斯特里特（Roger Street）警长坐在后座上，他的头发染过并重新做过造型，以更贴近伊恩·麦凯的形象。他的手臂用吊带固定着，以示受伤，但实际上是为了掩盖一个双向无线电。警探们随身携带了一个黑色手提箱，里面装着50万英镑，由几捆假钞组成，顶部铺有一层薄薄的真钞。里面还有一个电子寻星设备。按照M3的指示，劳斯莱斯沿着北环路驶向A-10高速公路，随后停在剑桥路与教堂街交叉口的公共电话亭旁。假扮伊恩的斯特里特警长下了
vehicle and entered the phone box. At exactly 10pm, he received the call from M3 who directed him to a second phone box on the corner of Southbury Road, a 40-minute drive up the A-10. At this second phone box, M3 called and said, look on the floor, you'll see a Piccadilly cigarette packet with your instructions. Sure enough, the seemingly discarded cigarette pack lay at the detective's feet, signed M3. A piece of paper tucked inside listed the next phase of instructions. The suitcase was to be taken to the corner of Cambridge Road and to Dane End, yet another locale in London's northeast. Two paper flowers would be stuck in the embankment, acting as markers for where the suitcase was to be deposited. The Rolls Royce reached the corner of Cambridge Road and to Dane
车，走进了电话亭。恰好在晚上10点，他接到了M3的电话，M3指引他前往A-10公路上一处需要驾驶40分钟、位于索伯里路拐角处的第二个电话亭。在这个第二个电话亭里，M3打来电话说，看地上，你会看到一包里面有你指示的皮卡迪利香烟盒。果不其然，那个看似被丢弃的烟盒就躺在侦探的脚边，上面签着M3。里面塞着的一张纸上列出了下一阶段的指示。手提箱必须被带到剑桥路和戴恩端（Dane End）的拐角处，这是伦敦东北部的又一个地点。两朵纸花将插在路堤上，作为放置手提箱的标记。劳斯莱斯在午夜时分到达剑桥路和戴恩
End at Midnight, where the detectives inside spotted the two handcrafted flowers arranged there. They were made from tissue paper and paper clips to look like carnations, one yellow and the other green. The detectives left the suitcase by the flowers and drove back to the phone box at the Cambridge Road and Church Street intersection, where M3 had advised they would receive a call regarding Muriel's location. Over 100 undercover police personnel kept a discrete watch of the suitcase from nearby buildings and vehicles awaiting the arrival of the stranger hired by M3 to pick it up. 40 were armed and outfitted with bulletproof vests, having been advised that in the event that Muriel and her kidnapper appeared, they should throw her to the ground to shield her
端的拐角处，车内的侦探们发现了那里摆放的两朵手工制作的花。它们是用纸巾和回形针做成的，看起来像康乃馨，一朵黄色，一朵绿色。侦探们把手提箱留在花旁，然后开车返回剑桥路与教堂街交叉口的电话亭，M3曾建议他们在那儿接听关于莫丽尔下落的电话。100多名便衣警察在附近的建筑物和车辆中对行李箱进行隐秘监视，等待M3雇来取走行李箱的陌生人出现。其中40人携带武器并穿防弹背心，接到指示称，如果莫丽尔和她的绑架者出现，他们应将她按倒在地以保护她的
body whilst other officers detained her at Ducta. Two officers watching from a taxi sided a dark coloured Volvo saloon car cruising around the area, occupied by a male driver and a bushy-haired passenger. One of the vehicle s rear lights was observed to be non-functional. Neither officer recorded the Volvo s license plate number, presuming it was one of the many undercover police cars circling the area. As time passed, the suitcase remained unclaimed and M3 made no further contact. Detective Street emerged from the phone box at the Cambridge Road and Church Street intersection, having never received the promised call regarding Muriel's whereabouts. At 2.30am, the operation was officially declared a bust.
身体，同时其他警官在达克塔将其拘留。两名在一辆出租车内观察的警官看到一辆深色沃尔沃轿车在该地区游荡，车内有一名男司机和一名蓬头垢面的乘客。据观察，该车的一盏尾灯不亮。两名警官都没有记录这辆沃尔沃的车牌号，以为它是盘旋在该地区的众多便衣警车之一。随着时间的推移，手提箱一直无人认领，M3也没有再进行联系。斯特里特警长从剑桥路与教堂街交叉口的电话亭里走了出来，始终没有接到关于莫丽尔下落的承诺电话。凌晨2点30分，该行动被正式宣布失败。
Two days after the failed ransom drop, M3 called the Mackay House and spoke with Ian, explaining why the suitcase went unclaimed. You know why I didn't even touch the suitcase. My boss, the head boy, was there. All the boys were there. We saw cars parked all round there. Did you know they were all police? He went on to mention he was now going to attend a meeting with the mafia bosses to set a time for Muriel's execution, saying, This organization's got money. I'm going to this meeting of the semi-intellectuals to plead for your mum. I'm fond of her, your mum, because she reminds me of my mum. M3 called again two hours later, appearing to have had a change of heart. He was now open to
the possibility of attempting another ransom drop, but this time the boys were insisting the delivery be made by Alec Mackay and his daughter Diane. The group suspected Ian was responsible for the police presence at the failed drop days earlier and no longer trusted him. On Thursday, February 5, the day after his wife's 56th birthday, Alec Mackay spoke with M3 as they discussed plans for the upcoming ransom drop. On the following day, the money was to be split between two white suitcases, with the father and daughter instructed to carry one each. Alec was directed to drive the Rolls-Royce to a public telephone box on Church Street in the North London District of Tottenham at 4pm and await further instructions.
The next day, Friday, February 6, Detective Inspector John Miners made up to look like Alec Mackay and a female police officer disguised as Diane set off to Tottenham in the Rolls-Royce. They reached the Church Street phone box as directed, where at 4pm, M3 rang and ordered the pair to head to a second phone box in London's East End District of Bethnal Green, a near 10km trip south. At Bethnal Green, M3 called again, instructing the duo to take the London Underground transit system to Wepping, where they were told to head to another specified phone box. The undercover officers boarded the train, each carrying a white suitcase containing the phony ransom money. They shared their compartment with several plainclothes police
officers, cautiously observing their movements. Upon reaching the phone box in Epping, M3 called to instruct the pair to take a taxi to Bishop's Thortford, a suburb just over 20km northward. From there, they were to head to Gates Garage, a petrol station and mechanic situated on a used car lot. Parked in the forecourt was a minivan with the license plate number UMH 587F. M3 ordered the suitcases be left beside the minivan. Warning, we deal with high-powered telescopic sided rifles, anyone illegal that attempts to interfere with the cases. We shall just let them have it. By the time the taxi arrived to the Gates Garage,
night had fallen and the area was teeming with hidden police officers. They were peering out from inside parked cars and cowering behind surrounding fences. The taxi pulled up alongside the minivan and the two suitcases were deposited as instructed. Detective Minas and his female colleague then returned to the phone box in Epping to await the next call from M3 regarding Muriel's whereabouts. Five minutes after the delivery, officers overseeing Gates Garage spotted a dark blue Volvo saloon car with a broken tail light driving slowly past the minivan. Its male driver was observed looking out towards the suitcases before driving off. At 9.35pm, the Volvo reappeared and circled around the lot twice,
driving by the suitcases each time. In the second instance, the vehicle almost slowed down to a halt but a car travelling behind bipped its horn, forcing the Volvo to speed up and drive onward in the direction of Bishop Storford's town centre. Over an hour later, at 10.47pm, the Volvo returned to the area with the driver now accompanied by a male passenger. Darkness prevented officers from identifying the vehicle's occupants, but it was observed that the passenger had dark coloured bushy hair and a mustache. Yet again, the Volvo slowly drove around the area before departing, leaving the cases behind. Less than 10 minutes later, at 11.00pm, two well-meaning members of the public noticed
the abandoned suitcases and called the police to report the suspicious items. Local police officers arrived at the scene, completely oblivious that a high-stakes ransom drop was underway. Undercover detectives watched on as the officers collected the cases and left, inadvertently thwarting their operation and forcing them to abandon it at 11.40pm. However, not all was lost. What seemed like yet another failure to secure Muriel's release actually provided detectives with a much needed major breakthrough. The dark blue Volvo Saloon car had now been spotted at both ransom drop attempts. Her vehicle matching its description was also cited by witnesses on the night of Muriel's abduction,
initially cruising around Arthur Street and later, parked in the driveway of St Mary's House around the time Muriel was abducted. Although its significance was unintentionally overlooked during the first ransom drop, when the vehicle reappeared at Gates Garage, officers recorded its license plate number, XGO 994G. On the morning of February 7, 1970, 40 days into the search for Muriel Mackay, a police convoy travelled down the long muddy drive of Rooks Farm, a ranch in the village of Stocking Pelham, approximately 50km northeast of London. The general area, M3, was known to operate from. The remote farmland contained 14 acres of pasture surrounding a two-story home,
its white facade run down and dated. Parked out front was a dark blue Volvo Saloon car with a broken taillight and the license plate number XGO 994G. The Volvo was registered to the wife of the farm's owner, 34-year-old Arthur Hussain, one of seven Hussain sons born in the Caribbean country of Trinidad. After emigrating to London in 1955, he worked as a ledger clerk until he was called upon for national service in 1960. Having little interest in the army and regularly absconding, Arthur's service ended in a six-month stint in military prison prior to being discharged for desertion. One officer held the opinion that Arthur Hussain was, quote,
immeasurably the worst soldier that has been my misfortune to have under me. In the following years, Arthur married a hairdresser 10 years his senior whom he met during his military service and to the pair started a family. He then followed in his father's footsteps to become a tailor, running his own business from a shopfront in Hackney. Arthur established a positive reputation for his craftsmanship and earned a decent wage of £150 a week. Arthur's prosperity fostered a desire to abandon his tailoring business and live the life of a wealthy country gentleman, so he took out a mortgage and purchased the dilapidated Rook's farm in 1967. In an attempt to portray himself worthy of his esteemed community, Arthur squandered
his earnings on lavish expenses, ensuring the Hussain family were in constant financial struggle. To pay the bills and support his lifestyle, Arthur continued his tailoring work from home while raising livestock for slaughter. Despite his hardships, Arthur boasted about money and expressed his dream to become a millionaire. His unfound arrogance and vanity soon irritating his acquaintances, who mockingly referred to him as King Hussain. In August 1969, the youngest Hussain brother, 21-year-old Nismah Dean, moved to Rook's farm to help look after the livestock while Arthur's wife and children visited extended family in Germany. Despite their relation, Arthur and Nismah Dean didn't look much like siblings. The smaller
of the two, Arthur was plump with large round facial features, bushy black hair and a thick mustache. Nismah Dean was tall and lean, with soft narrow facial features and a wad of dark hair neatly combed across his forehead. The differences between the pair extended beyond their physical appearances. Nismah Dean lacked the bravado of his older brother and was far more introverted and emotional. When the search for Muriel Mackay led police to Rook's farm, they identified Nismah Dean as the driver and Arthur as the passenger of the Volvo witness at the two ransom drop sites. The brothers were presented with a search warrant relating to the jewellery stolen from Muriel's home on the night of her abduction,
although finding these items were the least of the investigator's priorities. When shown the warrant, Arthur Hussain stated, I don't know nothing. I earned £150 a week. I'm a wealthy man. I don't deal in stolen property. You can look where you like. A thorough search of Rook's farm commenced. Officers inspected the entire property from the shed where two fierce guard dogs were kept, to the barns that accommodated the livestock, to the outbuilding that was used as a slaughterhouse. Inside the farmhouse, officers found a run-down residence full of worn furniture, including couches, a curved bar with a couple of stools,
a radiogram and a television set. While several upstairs bedrooms were sparsely furnished, a washing machine had recently burst, flooding the kitchen and a living space. Police summoned an architect and a builder to examine the property for any secret compartments or rooms. Their efforts to locate Muriel were futile. Police did uncover several items of interest, including a sawn-off shotgun, as well as an empty tin of two and a half inch elastoplast tape, which matched the strip found at the Mackay's home following Muriel's abduction. A total of six handcrafted paper flowers were discovered throughout the farmhouse,
a radiogram and a television set. While several upstairs bedrooms were sparsely furnished, a washing machine had recently burst, flooding the kitchen and a living space. Police summoned an architect and a builder to examine the property for any secret compartments or rooms. Their efforts to locate Muriel were futile. Police do uncover several items of interest, including a sawn-off shotgun, as well as an empty tin of two and a half inch elastoplast tape, which matched the strip found at the Mackay's home following Muriel's abduction. A total of six handcrafted paper flowers were discovered throughout the farmhouse,
identical to those used as markers during the first ransom drop attempt. An empty Piccadilly brand cigarette packet was also found, the same type left in the public phone box by M3 that contained the instructions that led detectives to the flowers. The cigarette packet used in the ransom drop bore Arthur Hussain's thumbprint, and the instructions inside were examined by a handwriting expert who determined the writing resembled Arthur's penmanship. Upon searching Arthur's sewing room, investigators were reminded of the three pieces of material clipped from Muriel's clothing that was sent to her family during her disappearance. Each piece of fabric had been cut in neat squares,
just like fabric samples a tailor would provide. A piece of paper found in the left pocket of a pair of Nismah Dean Hussain's trousers noted the license plate number of the minivan parked near Gates garage. The minivan was used as a marker during the second ransom drop attempt. Detectives also found a cardboard box in Nismah Dean's bedroom that contained an exercise book with several pages missing. The letters received from M3 were slid into the book and their ripped edges paired with the torn remains inside. The surface of the box also had indentations of the words off and St Mary's, which matched writing on the ransom note from M3 that read, he is not paid off for St Mary's house, and she said he hasn't the money,
but he can borrow from friends he knows. A palm print on the note matched Arthur Hussain, as did prints on a sheet of the People newspaper found at the Mackay's house the night Muriel was taken. As the search of Rook's farm continued, investigators spoke with a local farmer named Leonard Smith, who recently helped the Hussain's transports and furniture to their property following an auction. Leonard always kept the spare wheel and bill hook in his car, but he had to remove these items to unload the furniture. After making the delivery and returning home, Leonard realized he had accidentally left his wheel and bill hook at Rook's farm. The Hussain's later returned to the wheel, but not the bill hook, and when shown the one retrieved from the Mackay crime scene,
Leonard responded, that's my bill hook. I defy anybody to say it's not. Despite the overwhelming evidence implicating the two Hussain brothers in the abduction plot, investigators failed to find anything to prove Muriel Mackay was ever held at Rook's farm, or to explain what had become of her. Nevertheless, Arthur and Nismedine Hussain were placed under arrest and taken in separate police cars to Kingston Police Station, where they denied involvement in the crime. Both brothers gave alibis for the night of Muriel's disappearance, neither of which could be verified. When shown all the evidence that linked him to the crime, Arthur Hussain denied ever seeing the items and placed all the blame on his younger brother,
even though his finger and palm prints were present on several key exhibits. He agreed to provide a handwriting sample, but an expert concluded that Arthur deliberately disguised his penmanship to appear different to M3's ransom notes. In his sample, Arthur misspelled the word occasion with two S's, a unique error that was also present in M3's second letter to the Mackay's, where he wrote, we demand the full million pound in two occasions. Police spoke to Arthur's wife Elsa, who revealed she had taken the children to Germany to visit extended family from December 13, 1969 to January 3, 1970. Her trip, her husband, particularly encouraged. She didn't see Muriel at Rook's farm upon her return, nor did any of the guests who
visited the property while she was gone, leading investigators to believe with certainty that Muriel was killed within the first 48 hours of her abduction. This validated the earlier theory that Muriel had been forced to write the letters to her family all at once, within the initial hours of her captivity. According to Elsa, her husband's behavior became more secretive prior to her leaving for Germany. Arthur drove into London more often than usual, taking his younger brother with him, even though Nismar Dean's job was to stay home and complete chores on the farm. Elsa recalled a conversation with Arthur in the weeks leading up to her trip, during which he remarked, You know darling, there must be easier ways of making money than this.
At the time, Rupert Murdoch's multi-million pound purchase of News of the World was making headlines, and Arthur remarked that the tycoon would be worth a lot of money if he was held captive, stating he ought to be careful with all this publicity. When Elsa returned from Germany, she found Rook's farm in Shambles. Most notably, curtains had been torn off the railings in the master bedroom. She questioned if a fight had taken place in there, prompting Arthur to go berserk as he angrily denied the suggestion. Elsa then found a women's green vest amongst the blankets of the bed. Angered by the implication her husband may be having an affair,
she stormed downstairs and tossed the item of clothing in the fireplace and watched it burn. In the following days, Arthur was angry and erratic. At one stage, he ordered Elsa and the children to leave the house, threatening that something would happen to them if they refused. Nismar Dean was acting equally bizarre and was clearly overcome with nerves. He held his shaking hands up at Elsa, stating that they could kill and begged her not to leave him alone with Arthur. Elsa later remarked, the way the boy was acting that night, he was guilty of something terrible. Without a shadow of a doubt, it was Nismar Dean who killed Mrs. Mackay. Arthur could be violent, but he could not kill. He couldn't stand to the sight of
blood. It wasn't a stretch for investigators to envisage Nismar Dean as the one who murdered Muriel, considering the young man had two previous convictions for violent crimes. Elsa's comments, combined with Arthur's unwillingness to cooperate, led to the investigative spotlight being placed on the younger of the two siblings. The brothers were known to have a temperamental relationship in which Arthur asserted control over Nismar Dean, who was considered weak-willed and easily led. Records showed that Nismar Dean had once made a police complaint alleging his brother had assaulted him, but when an officer attended Rook's farm to investigate, Nismar Dean insisted the situation was settled. Unlike his steadfast and confident
brother, Nismar Dean broke down during police interrogations, crying, Kill me. Kill me. Arthur always gets me into trouble. Kill me now. When asked about his whereabouts on the night of December 29, 1969, Nismar Dean trembled and shook his head, saying, Where did Arthur say I was? I was with my brother, Arthur. When asked if he went to Wimbledon, Nismar Dean remained silent, prompting officers to question if something was wrong. He answered, I want to die. Let me die. My brother Arthur will kill me. He beats me. I can't speak. I mustn't speak. Let me see Arthur. Nismar Dean was also asked to provide a handwriting sample and made no effort to
disguise his penmanship. As his writing didn't match M3's ransom notes, investigators believed Arthur had likely authored them. When shown the bill hook, bailing twine and a strip of a luster plaster retrieved from the Mackay house, Nismar Dean closed his eyes and cried, Let me die. His agony increased when the pieces of material cut from Muriel's clothing were presented to him as he begged officers, Let me die. Why won't I die? Experts compared the tape recordings of the phone calls from Muriel's abductor to the voices of the Hussain brothers and noted strong similarities. Both Hussain brothers were asked to speak into a telephone that was connected to the tape recorder at the Mackay residence.
Arthur agreed to the request, but Nismar Dean refused. It was clear to those who had heard extracts of the M3 audio tapes that the man on the phone had been Nismar Dean Hussain. When asked whether Muriel Mackay was dead, Nismar Dean fell silent and trance-like. Even his solicitor pressed to find out if Muriel was still alive and where she was located, but Nismar Dean hung his head and said nothing. Eventually, Nismar Dean became emotional and told an unsettling story in which he borrowed a bill hook from a farmer friend to chop up a dead calf. When asked what he did with the calf's remains, he stated, I fed it to the dogs. As for the bones and head, he explained, they were put out with the rubbish.
Based on this story, investigators were certain Nismar Dean was using the calf as a proxy for Muriel Mackay and he was actually describing the violent way in which he and Arthur disposed of her body. Lost in police custody, Arthur Hussain reached boiling point, telling officers, if you've got anything on me, then book me. Both he and Nismar Dean were formally charged with seven counts, including the abduction, imprisonment and murder of Muriel Mackay. The other indictments were in relation to threats and blackmail, specifically the demands of a million pounds by menaces from Alec Mackay. Efforts to locate Muriel Mackay continued for weeks, with the fire brigade draining the ponds on Rooks Farm and trudging through the Outlying Creek,
as lines of police officers searched surrounding fields, forests and farmland. The property itself was extensively excavated, but to no avail. No trace of Muriel Mackay was ever recovered. Thus, the first kidnapping for ransom trial in the United Kingdom's contemporary legal history commenced with the victim's outcome remaining a mystery. The case was a media sensation, with the public curious to find out how a jury could find someone guilty of murder when there was no body to prove it. Both Arthur and Nismar Dean Hussain pleaded not guilty and went to trial at London's Old Bailey Criminal Court on Monday, September 14, 1970. In his five-hour opening address to a
packed courtroom, prosecution attorney general Sir Peter Rawlinson stated, this was a brutal and ruthless scheme to kidnap a wife and by menaces to extort from her husband a vast sum of money. Can you imagine the horror of a woman, one minute beside the fire waiting for her husband to return, and minutes later, gagged and trust, then driven away in the darkness? Sir Rawlinson went on to detail the days and weeks in which the Mackay family were subjected to a systematic series of threats via telephone and letter by the defendants, adding, we may infer that those who threatened to kill did kill. The court was told of Arthur Hussain's delusions of grandeur, which spawned his obsessive, yet
unachievable aspirations to become a millionaire. Sir Rawlinson alleged that the brothers hatched the plan to kidnap for ransom in late October 1969, after watching British journalist David Frost conduct a televised interview with Rupert Murdoch. During the interview, Rupert's recent takeover of the news of the world group was touched upon, including the multimillions he paid to secure its ownership. As Zem3 once explained over the phone to Alec Mackay, his target was originally intended to be Rupert's wife Anna. The prosecution alleged that in late December 1969, the brothers tailed Rupert Murdoch's Rolls Royce from the news of the world group office, with the intention of locating his private residence. Sir Rawlinson, quote,
and if that is what they did, they must have traced the vehicle to St Mary's house, Arthur Road, Wimbledon. That was not the home of the news of the world group chairman, Mr. Rupert Murdoch, but the home of the acting chairman, Mr. Alec Mackay. Throughout the 40 days of Muriel's disappearance, her abductor had made 18 phone calls and penned five letters to the Mackay family. The prosecution pointed out that from the moment police arrived to Rook's farm, there had been complete and utter silence from the otherwise talkative kidnapper. As soon as the Attorney General ended the opening address for the prosecution,
Nismedine Hussain's defense attorney Douglas Drakeott made a surprise announcement. He wished to make seven voluntary admissions on behalf of his client. They began with a visit to the Greater London Council on December 19, 1969, where Nismedine unsuccessfully attempted to obtain Rupert Murdoch's home address. Then, on February 1, 1970, the date of the first ransom drop attempt, he placed two handcrafted paper flowers near the intersection of Dane End and Cambridge Road. On February 6, 1970, during the second ransom drop attempt, he drove the Volvo to Gates garage at around 8pm to look for two suitcases, waiting around for about an hour before
尼斯迈丁·侯赛因的辩护律师道格拉斯·德雷科特做出了一个令人意外的宣布。他希望代表其当事人做出七项自愿供认。它们始于1969年12月19日对大伦敦议会的一次访问，当时尼斯迈丁试图获取鲁珀特·默多克的家庭住址但没有成功。然后，在1970年2月1日，即第一次企图支付赎金的日期，他在丹恩恩德和剑桥路交汇处附近放置了两朵手工纸花。1970年2月6日，在第二次企图支付赎金期间，他驾驶沃尔沃汽车在大约晚上8点左右来到盖茨车库寻找两个手提箱，逗留了一个多小时后
sighting them on the pavement opposite the miniband. He then drove to a nearby pub in Bishop's Stortford, where his brother Arthur was drinking, arriving at about 10pm. Nismedine admitted he drove back to Gates garage at 10.47pm, and he also admitted that the note found in his pants pocket featuring the minivan's license plate number was in his handwriting. Although none of the admissions openly implicated Arthur Hussain in murals of duction or murder, the mere suggestion sent his defense counsel into immediate damage control. They explained to the court that although Nismedine was acknowledging some involvement in the crime, Arthur was not, and would continue to profess his innocence of all charges.
看到了停在小巴对面人行道上的它们。随后他驱车前往位于彼得斯托福德的一个附近酒吧，他的弟弟亚瑟在那里喝酒，大约晚上10点到达。尼斯迈丁承认他在晚上10点47分开车返回盖茨车库，他还承认在他裤兜里找到的写有小货车车牌号的便条是他的笔迹。尽管这些供认都没有公开指证亚瑟·侯赛因参与绑架或谋杀，但这种暗示还是让他的辩护律师立即开始进行危机公关。他们向法庭解释说，尽管尼斯迈丁承认参与了部分犯罪，但亚瑟并没有，并且将继续坚称自己对所有指控无罪。
Regardless, Nismedine's revelations served as the beginning of a battle between the two defense teams to implicate the other brother. The ensuing conflict was advantageous to the prosecution, who argued that the brother's attempts to blame each other proved the guilt lay with both. The defense's argument hinged on whether or not the crown proved that Muriel's death was the result of murder. Arthur Hussain's defense attorney Barry Hudson stated, Although the defense primarily relied on the fact that no evidence of Muriel Mackay was recovered at Rooks Farm, the prosecution narrowed in on the evidence that was found elsewhere that linked directly back to the Hussain's property. The billhook, the elastoplast tape, the torn sheets
无论如何，尼斯迈丁的披露拉开了两个辩护团队互相指责对方是另一个兄弟的战斗的序幕。随后的冲突对控方有利，他们辩称兄弟俩互相指责的企图证明了两人都有罪。辩护方的论点取决于王室是否证明了穆里尔的死是谋杀的结果。亚瑟·侯赛因的辩护律师巴里·哈德森表示，尽管辩护主要依赖于在鲁克斯农场没有找到穆里尔·麦凯的证据这一事实，但控方将重点缩小到了在其他地方找到的、直接与侯赛因家族财产有关的证据上。砍树刀、弹性塑料胶带、撕下的
of note paper, the cigarette packet, the handcrafted flowers, and the Volvo. On October 6, 1970, after four hours deliberation, the jury returned a verdict of guilty on all counts for both Arthur and Nismedine Hussain. Just the seabag sure, quote, The kidnapping and confinement of Mrs. Mackay was cold-blooded and abominable. She was snatched from the security of her home, and so long as she remained alive, she was reduced to terrified distress. This crime will shock and revolt every right-minded person. The punishment must be such that law-abiding citizens may feel safe in their homes. Arthur Hussain was sentenced to life imprisonment for the murder of Muriel Mackay,
记事本纸页、烟盒、手工花以及沃尔沃汽车。1970年10月6日，经过四个小时的审议，陪审团对亚瑟和尼斯迈丁·侯赛因的所有指控做出有罪裁决。正如法官所说，引用：“麦凯夫人的绑架和拘禁是冷血且令人发指的。她从自己家的安全环境中被强行掳走，只要她还活着，她就一直处于惊恐痛苦之中。这起罪行将震撼并激怒每一个思想端正的人。惩罚必须让守法公民在自己的家中感到安全。”亚瑟·侯赛因因谋杀穆里尔·麦凯被判处终身监禁，
with an additional 25 years for her kidnapping. Throughout the trial, references were made to Nismedine's unsettling behavior during police questioning, in which he expressed on multiple occasions a fear of Arthur and a desire to die. In response, the jury made a recommendation of leniency for Nismedine on the belief he was less a willing participant and more a reluctant accomplice in the crime, acting on the orders of his threatening older brother. Just as sure, quote, I am not sure whether you are in any degree less culpable, but the jury's view is that you were under the influence of your brother, and I have to regard the possibility that this was so. As such, Nismedine Hussain was sentenced
因绑架罪被加判25年。在整个审判过程中，人们多次提及尼斯迈丁在警方盘问期间令人不安的行为，他在其中多次表达了对亚瑟的恐惧以及寻死的愿望。作为回应，陪审团建议对尼斯迈丁从轻处罚，因为他们认为他与其说是自愿参与者，不如说是犯罪中不情愿的从犯，是在其具有威胁性的哥哥的命令下行事的。正如法官所说，引用：“我不确定你在多大程度上减轻了罪责，但陪审团的看法是你在你哥哥的影响下行事，我必须考虑到这种可能性。”因此，尼斯迈丁·侯赛因被判处
to life imprisonment for murder, but only given 15 years for kidnapping. Both brothers appealed based on their belief that the prosecution did not prove the crux of their case, that Muriel Mackay was taken to Rook's Farm where she was murdered, and that no other people may have been involved in the crime. On March 29, 1971, their applications were heard before the Court of Appeal, the presiding judges reminding the court that although no trace of Muriel was found at Rook's Farm, there was plenty of other evidence implicating the brothers in her death. The appellate judges dismissed the applications and ruled the sentence given to each brother was correct, as, quote, no more terrible crime could be conjured up.
终身监禁（谋杀），但绑架罪仅被判处15年。两兄弟都进行了上诉，因为他们认为控方没有证明其案件的核心，即穆里尔·麦凯被带到鲁克斯农场并在那里被谋杀，并且没有其他人可能参与这起犯罪。1971年3月29日，他们的上诉申请在上诉法院受审，主审法官提醒法庭，尽管在鲁克斯农场没有找到穆里尔的踪迹，但还有大量其他证据暗示兄弟俩参与了她的死亡。上诉法官驳回了申请，并裁定对每个兄弟的判决是正确的，因为引用：“再也没有比这更可怕的罪行能想出来了。”
Following the conviction of Arthur and Nismedine Hussain for the murder of Muriel Mackay, her husband fronted the media and stated, I wish to God I knew what happened to Muriel. All I want to know is where my wife has been buried so that I can go into place and flowers. In a desperate bid to obtain information about the whereabouts of his wife's remains to give her a proper burial, Alec Mackay wrote letters to both Arthur and Nismedine, but received no response. John Lisners, author of The Rise and Fall of the Murdoch Empire, visited Nismedine during his incarceration at Winston Green Prison in Birmingham. John was escorted by Arthur's wire felsa, who sought the location of Muriel to pass the information on to the Mackay family.
在亚瑟和尼斯迈丁·侯赛因因谋杀穆里尔·麦凯而被定罪后，她的丈夫出面面对媒体并表示：“我真希望上帝知道穆里尔发生了什么。我只想知道我的妻子被埋在什么地方，这样我就可以去那个地方献花。”为了拼命获取有关他妻子遗体下落的信息以便给她举行一场体面的葬礼，亚克·麦凯给亚瑟和尼斯迈丁写了信，但没有收到任何回复。《默多克帝国的兴衰》一书的作者约翰·里斯纳斯在伯明翰温斯顿格林监狱服刑期间探访了尼斯迈丁。约翰由亚瑟的未婚妻陪同，她寻求穆里尔的下落以便将信息转达给麦凯家族。
During this meeting, Nismedine spoke of Muriel's abduction, explaining that in the early evening of December 29, 1969, he and Arthur got drunk at the Victoria Sporting Club in London before heading off to conduct the kidnapping. When asked how Muriel died, Nismedine trembled with emotion, before stating that the prison governor had advised him not to reveal what they had done with Muriel's body. In November 1987, Arthur Hussain applied for parole as he approached his 20th year in prison. The parole board denied the application, deciding his case would be considered again in February 1993. In the intervening period, Arthur's health declined and he was transferred to Washworth Hospital in Liverpool for an undisclosed illness. He remained hospitalised
在这次会面中，尼斯迈丁谈到了穆里尔的绑架事件，解释说在1969年12月29日傍晚，他和亚瑟在伦敦的维多利亚体育俱乐部喝醉了酒，然后出发去实施绑架。当被问及穆里尔是如何死去时，尼斯迈丁情绪激动地颤抖着，随后表示监狱长曾建议他不要透露他们对穆里尔的尸体做了什么。1987年11月，亚瑟·侯赛因在即将迎来第20年刑期之际申请假释。假释委员会拒绝了该申请，决定在1993年2月重新审理他的案件。在此期间，亚瑟的健康状况恶化，由于一种未公开的疾病，他被转移到利物浦的沃什沃思医院。他一直住院
during February 1993, missing the date of his second parole hearing. He reapplied for a review in September 1994, but his request was denied by the Home Secretary. In 1996, Arthur filed a complaint to the European Court of Human Rights. He claimed the refusal to review his parole application was a breach of his rights, as he believed he had a high chance of being released as he had served enough time and presented no risk to society. The Human Rights Commission determined Arthur's complaint was manifestly ill-founded and ruled, quote, the commission unanimously declares the application inadmissible. Arthur Hussain died in prison in 2009.
直到1993年2月，错过了第二次假释听证会的日期。他在1994年9月重新申请复审，但他的请求被内政大臣拒绝。1996年，亚瑟向欧洲人权法院提起申诉。他声称拒绝审查他的假释申请是对他权利的侵犯，因为他相信自己有很高的释放机会，因为他已经服刑足够长的时间且对社会不构成风险。人权委员会裁定亚瑟的申诉明显毫无根据，并裁决，引用：“委员会一致宣布该申请不可受理。”亚瑟·侯赛因于2009年在狱中去世。
Unlike his older brother, after serving just 20 years of his life sentence, Nismedine Hussain was granted parole and deported to his home country of Trinidad, where he faded away into obscurity. Nevertheless, the notoriety of the Hussain brothers resulted in life-like figures of the pair being created for the Madame to Swords Wax Museum in London. The popular tourist attraction once boasted an exhibition titled The Chamber of Horrors, which featured waxworks of infamous killers and historical figures, in which the models of Arthur and Nismedine Hussain were put on display. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
与他的哥哥不同，尼斯迈丁·侯赛因在服完终身监禁的短短20年后，便获准假释并被驱逐出境回到他的祖国特立尼达，并在那里渐渐淡出人们的视线，湮没无闻。然而，侯赛因兄弟的恶名导致伦敦杜莎夫人蜡像馆为两人制作了逼真的蜡像。这个广受欢迎的旅游景点曾经拥有一个名为“恐怖之屋”的展览，其中展出了声名狼藉的杀手和历史人物的蜡像，亚瑟和尼斯迈丁·侯赛因的模型也在其中展出。目前该剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。